ca non nous ont pas vraiment surprise un
dea puisque bon sur le terrain on voyait
bien que les conditions étaient
compliquées à mettre en oeuvre ces deux
reprises décalées pour lui c'est
justement n'est pas très surprenante
il n'y a pas grand chose de nouveau qui
a été annoncé donc sur les quinze élèves
maximum par classe
bon c'est déjà été évoquée depuis très
longtemps et qui sera compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre sur la le port du
masque à la fois à la fois donc des
personnels encadrants professeur j
technique et cetera c'est évidemment une
bonne chose ainsi que tout ce qu'on
demandait et le fait de rendre
obligatoire également pour les élèves le
collège alors on espère que quand la
reprise on dit si sera évoqué ce soir ce
sera également le cas celle-ci quelque
chose qui est pour l'essentiel mais
encore une fois qui avec ce décalage de
la reprise qui sera d'ailleurs
différentes selon les départements dans
les évidences effectivement là qu'on est
un département qui est très touché que
là on est beaucoup des pôles ont des
transports et c'est que ça sera sans
doute plus compliqué dans notre
département